Donald Trump is the first former
president to be charged with a crime but
he isn't the first former presidential
candidate to be indicted or for that
indictment to involve a hush money
payment just over 10 years ago Democrat
John Edwards stood trial for money and
gifts given to his mistress there's
nothing illegal about giving somebody
hush money not to talk about it if it
was done specifically for the purpose of
promoting your candidacy for a federal
office that's where the problem comes in
here's how the two cases compare and
what we can learn about the potential
strengths and weaknesses of the one
against Trump from the other
let's start with what happened with John
Edwards a senator from North Carolina he
became John Kerry's 2004 running mate
before running in the 2008 presidential
primary against Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton
he did okay in Iowa but quickly dropped
out it's time for me to step step aside
so that history can so that so that uh
history can blaze its path that year
tabloid story surfaced about him having
a child from an affair which after two
years of denying tabloid trash is full
of lives he admitted to the Scandal had
everything could be the biggest
political sex scandal of Our Generation
I just turned him and said you're so hot
hundreds of thousands of dollars given
to him by supporters private jet flights
and luxury hotel rooms while his wife
was battling terminal cancer John
Edwards sex tape details revealed it was
a huge scandal at the time people loved
Elizabeth Edwards Elizabeth Edwards
really helped John Edwards reputation
mammothly so they really sold themselves
as you know a loving everyday American
family
here's what the justice department said
happened during the campaign campaign
worker rielle Hunter pregnant with John
Edward's daughter while his wife
Elizabeth was dined of cancer was given
cash luxury hotel stays apartments and
rides on private planes by a wealthy
member of his campaign and a wealthy
donor to be kept out of sight these were
also given to a close aide who falsely
claimed to be the baby's father none of
this money came directly through the
campaign or Edwards himself prosecutors
argued Edwards orchestrated this web of
money and that the payments were made to
help his campaign a Federal grand jury
indicted Edwards on six Federal counts
of campaign Finance law violations John
Edwards is a lousy human being but I
think this is a really lousy and flimsy
criminal case Melanie Sloan founded this
government accountability group and
still works in ethics and campaign law
she followed the Edwards trial closely
there was no evidence that John Edwards
personally gave the money regardless of
whether that had happened there still
would have been the question of about
why is the money a campaign donation is
it being spent to advance your candidacy
or is it money being spent to hush this
up for some other reason I.E to protect
your family while I do not believe I did
anything illegal or ever thought I was
doing anything illegal
I did an awful awful lot that was wrong
New York prosecutors argue with Trump
the reason was clearly because of the
2016 election Trump denies any
wrongdoing here's what prosecutors say
happened
in 2016 porn star stormy daniels's
lawyer went to the National Enquirer
yes that same tabloid to sell her story
about an alleged sexual encounter with
Trump from a decade prior the CEO of the
tabloids publisher David pecker was able
to connect her with Trump's lawyer
Michael Cohen who eventually paid her a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars to
keep quiet Cohen was later reimbursed by
submitting monthly invoices for Legal
Services which were paid by Trump
through the Trump organization New York
prosecutors say those payment records
were false business records the 34
charges come out of the same set of
facts each time there's an invoice and
each time there's a payment and each
time there's a bookkeeping record that
is all the crime of falsifying the
business records in order to cover up a
crime with edwards's case this donor had
died and this one was a hundred and
never testified a jury acquitted him on
one charge and deadlocked on another
five so the trial ended in a mistrial
juror said there wasn't enough evidence
tying him to the money we all thought
that he knew but there just was not the
evidence there to prove it it was just a
lack of evidence
with Trump prosecutors say they have
evidence that he was involved in the
payments besides Trump's name and
signature on the checks and that the
intent of the payments was to help his
campaign Cohen has already pleaded
guilty and served time in jail for these
payments being campaign related and
prosecutors say Trump directed Cohen to
delay daniels's payment until after the
election because then it would not
matter if the story becomes public
prosecutors also point to a similar
payment made to another woman who
alleged she had a sexual encounter with
Trump Karen McDougall they say pecker
and Cohen worked out a deal that
ultimately paid McDougall a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for her silence
and that there are audio recordings of
trump and Cohen discussing this
Arrangement testimony from pecker says
he made the connections to the two women
to ensure no damaging allegations would
be published before the election and
thereby influence that election
the indictment and statement of facts
particularly do not suggest in any way
shape or form that this was ever about
hiding it from his wife in fact they
make it very very clear that what they
want to do is hide it during the course
of the presidential election Federal
prosecutors when charging Cohen in 2019
declined to indict Trump who was still
in office
these charges were filed in a New York
State Court experts like Sloan argued
that this case may not even be as strong
as the one against Edwards which was in
federal court even with these
connections I don't think this is a slam
dunk by any means the fact that it's not
being a federal case that it's actually
not being done by the justice department
when you have a federal campaign Finance
law that is being bootstrapped into a
state court that is unprecedented Trump
pleaded not guilty to all 34 charges he
denies the alleged sexual encounters
this fake case was brought only to
interfere with the upcoming 2024
election
and it should be dropped immediately
immediately he's not likely to face jail
time if convicted and the trial if it
happens isn't expected to move quickly
the next court date is in December of
2023.
foreign